happy
batman day people so excited to do
today's video we got a bunch of
awesome batman day celebration artwork
to look at
and then we got some crazy flash cameo
rumors to go over
yeah we're both gonna be in it there's
some great stuff that's been releasing
online
it's all just to distract from the ray
fisher wb stuff that's the only reason
all this is the only reason batman day
exists in general that's right they were
like someday we're gonna need to
distract from a major situation
our comic book movies so let's honor
batman today by looking at some stuff
that came out
on the internet and i'm sure by the time
i'm editing this and the time this is up
more and more things will be going up
online let's start with
snyder cuts very own zack snyder today
he put out earlier
uh this crazy look it looks like a comic
book man that is
beautiful how does this not get you
excited for the snyder god jeez
oh it makes me wish for a black and
white version it looks so
good look at this photo guys
he said uh batman is all of us he is a
rage at injustice he
stands alone as we all wish we could in
the face of a corrupt system which
wishes to oppress and exploit he is that
man this is so poor i didn't read this
he's so poetic he is that broken child
searching the dark alleys of the human
soul to bring balance to the world
hashtag batman day that that is
a big part of what i think it resonates
and what people love about batman
said jesus he should make a batman movie
next time
and then the official twitter account of
the snyder cut the director's cut of
justice league they put out this photo
saying want a closer look at batman and
the snyder cut i love how these photos
that have been coming out of ben affleck
just showing how
like big he is yeah i know how buffy
he is and it is like a towering presence
yeah yeah one you really get a look at
the musculature like this is a pretty
well lit image and he does like even
just in the suit look that much
more menacing so i'm hoping to see that
come through in the movie
it's a great photo it is thanks
snydercuff for releasing that and then
of course
we got some that uh matt reeves
retweeted this one and told me
batman's a batman for matt reeves
official twitter page celebrating batman
day with an illustration from
zinkevich the batman and this artwork is
inspired by
uh robert pattinson's batman look how
beautiful this is yeah
it's like he's coming out of a gun but
the gun is an alleyway
actually if you follow it from the cape
it looks like he's a ghost emerging from
a tunnel
yeah like a shadow overcome
encompassing the city it's gorgeous this
is like badass and haunting
all at the same time that's like the
myth taking shape and visual form
and then matt reeves he put this bad boy
out oh
um i love this i'm vengeance the hell
are you supposed to be
so this is artwork that's inspired to
obviously look like a more vintage
batman
comic book but it's uh a take on that
robert pattinson on vengeance moment
this is
great i would love a poster of this one
right here yeah right
every photo that's been released today
this is the one or like i gotta put this
on like the wall
you know so good and it and it vaguely
makes me hope that there will be like
you know the new batman movie looks like
it'll be a very you know
serious you know noir but it also makes
me hope for some of the pulp that this
alludes to because this looks like the
dark pulp you know like the pulp that's
pulpy but serious you know
oh and because batman day i want to
share with you guys what my sister got
me for my birthday this month one second
drum roll it's an unboxing it's an
unofficial unboxing right now
oh look at that oh
batman david oh wait i didn't even show
you the best part yeah turn off all the
lights
i'm gregory
[Laughter]
i'm alfred this is so cool this is so
awesome
and i flash that whenever i need you to
help me edit a video
i love that thank you again megan that's
a beautiful gift crazy how the superhero
has
a special holiday i wish la still wasn't
on lockdown in so many parts so that way
we could go to the
center of the city and light the bat
signal again oh remember
that that was a beautiful day a great
day you know what's funny is today is
also national talk like a pirate day and
i've seen that there's apparently a
batman pirate comic as well
oh cool so that's everything and boss
logic put this
out as well one of the best artists in
the business who i'm so surprised
is not getting hired for films yet yeah
but he put this out where he's got a red
version of it
and he's got a black and white version
of it isn't that sexy that is beautiful
that is so sexy i hope we see a shot
like that in this movie it's like the
batman animated series
meets matt reeves is batman so goofy
well yeah so cool
it literally looks like you photographed
the comic book in real life yeah
it is like it's so picturesque
absolutely in love with it i hope more
people start sharing throughout the day
because these have been absolutely
beautiful and a way to celebrate
the greatest comic book hero of all time
my personal opinion
right next to polka dot man
and then segwaying into other news we
have
so much rumors of what's to come
and this is coming from one of the main
sources of the rumor mill who can be
right a lot of the time daniel r p
k there's one particular cameo here
which i'm very excited for so there's
rumors
that we're gonna get tom welling to uh
make an appearance in the flash movie
you know of course we already got bat
the two batman confirmed
and tom welling again will refuse to
suit up as superman why not
even though i felt like what they did
with him in the cw crossover series
chrysler infinite earth i thought that
was a proper way to kind of put a
a seal on the tom welling journey
because there's a pretty
clear conclusion that he he gave up his
powers in there so i don't know what he
would be doing here other than just a
cameo
but the man i just don't think likes
wearing the suit
and then he got grant gustin who's
rumored to be here which i think would
be
an absolutely wonderful cameo that would
be great
you know the it's really hard for me to
wrap my head around someone else who can
top grant gus's portrayal of the flash
i think uh if he were to came in here
after ezra miller cameoed in the cw
series that would be a great way to pay
it forward
plus it'll mean that dc gets to beat
marvel to including their tv universe in
the movies
yeah there's more i want to comment
about that in a second there's been a
lot of rumors as well that they've been
that they've been approaching people
like christian bale george clooney val
kilmer to try to make appearances
in here to try to get all the batman
basically to make an appearance and at
this point with all the batman i'm kind
of like well why not you've come this
far
it would only make more sense to just
get all the batman to be included
but the confusing element of that if you
try to get
val kilmer and george clooney the
confusing part of that
is they were replacements for
michael keaton yes that was the same
timeline that's essential that's the
same
bruce wayne that's the same batman where
as opposed to you're establishing these
guys are all
separate universes and they're colliding
in this one movie
that's where i think it can be confusing
if you really want to get caught up in
canon and continuity and all that crap
this one though is the big rumor which
uh mark guggenheim said that he did
approach him here's the quote you know
to be honest with you because i never
wanted to lie on these things that was
yeah i actually did
we did reach out to nick cage all right
superman which would be awesome you know
like
the superman movie that never was
and for the kind of meme personality
that nicholas cage has turned into and i
think a lot of us
have that itching desire of that that
movie sounds like it probably wasn't
going to be that
all that great or at least not the
superman everyone envisions
yeah i think though to bring this to
life here and
it would just be so much fun it would be
a blast and it would be us
a different arena of wish fulfillment
yeah because you don't have to spend an
entire movie's worth of money on it but
yeah you can acknowledge it with the
multiverse i mean
those i feel like multiverses open you
up to humor and that's another thing
that you know dc has been working to add
in and so i feel like that would be
a wonderful self-aware thing to throw in
because
you know of course like we all want to
see what uh nick cage's superman would
have looked like
of course i mean john schnapp who passed
away a couple years ago who did the
documentary the death of superman lives
i
i feel like that brought a lot more
light to people wanting to see nicholas
cage at least do
something in the suit you know because
you know he's not going to do something
generic
and he's a huge superman fan isn't his
his son his name
kyle or jorel one of them i forget which
one it is but he's a major major
superman fan he's a big comic book fan
in general
and you know after he was like inspired
spider-man you are
and then uh he was even big daddy and
kick-ass being like coming full circle
you could play a spider-man essentially
a batman and then he could play a
superman
that'd be so cool this cameo out of them
all i would be the most excited to check
this one out yeah that's a cameo that
would get my ticket
sold regardless you know even more so
than michael keaton
it just has to be a couple minutes it
just has to be a minute honestly you
know it doesn't have to be a character
that's one of those cameos i'm like
thank you that's just so
fun you know he gotta do it he gotta be
superman yeah
that's i think that's partly it too is
like with with somebody like a michael
keaton or like a legacy
character that that counts to this
universe in a big way i i kind of get
worried about how they're gonna
incorporate them but yeah something like
this as long as the movie itself has a
good grip on its tone
yeah like the risk seems very low and
the reward seems very high
yeah at this point with what they're
doing with the flash movie
i'm down for them to uh make everyone
cameo in here
and to see the the crisis on infinite
earth's series already
made it clear that everything's
connected they've already made it clear
that like there's
it's a galaxy and then all these
universes we're all connected all these
worlds are
uh have some type of linkage right
however let's face it the movies make
a lot more money they they get a lot
more viewers and this would only
solidify it and probably make it clearer
for all the audiences
who did not watch crisis on infinite
earths who did not watch
uh that show because i think sometimes
there could be a lot more pressure with
christ on infinite earth those
crossovers because you have a
crap ton of episodes you'd have to catch
up on to really make sure you're not
missing out on any piece of information
right yeah whereas here you have a
handful of movies
and you can add the shows if you want to
and i hope
at this point i'm actually hoping this
sh this movie gets
weirder and tries to include some of the
animated properties like if they can get
really bizarre really really bonkers
because harley quinn is a pretty big hit
and it just got renewed for season three
i just finished season two it is a
wonderful series but if they can try to
include something do it roger rabbit
some weird animated universe for like a
couple minutes
and if it's funny because the thing is i
don't know what tone this movie's gonna
be but i imagine it has to have this
awareness of being funny
and imaginative i would want it to be
broadly imaginative which yeah opens you
up to
to quirk if not things that are overtly
funny yeah
yeah and i hope doom patrol gets to make
a cameo but if they can do something
where they
they do link all the shows and make it
very clear
maybe they can time travel to a part
where uh ezra miller did not choke
his family see where he goes in there
what if that was a big publicity stunt
and that was really just being shot for
the movie just to put it in the film
where he
travels there and like what ryan
reynolds did in the end of deadpool 2.
he travels there and then takes ezra
miller off of him and be like you don't
want to do that what a weird
publicity that'd be genius it's not
gonna happen
it's not true but it would be genius if
they did i suppose so because yeah we
would be wondering forever
all right guys well what do you think
about all these flash cameos are you
going to be doing anything to celebrate
batman day i kind of am i'm going to
drive an hour and a half to go watch
tennant tonight
watch robert pattinson on screen that's
batman yeah
i could just watch hbo max stuff i mean
nolan directed it
our past it's not batman but listen to
batman whatever guys subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell
keep a lookout for our boys reaction
tomorrow last but not least
rosa parra now if there's a hero out
there
that we need but don't deserve it's rose
it's rosa
rosa i'm so proud of you i saw this week
we keep talking about how you keep
climbing this ladder of being a critic
and now you are a verified critic for
rotten tomatoes
we've even tried did not pan out
yeah but now you are and you've been in
this pursuit
way less than us so congratulations rosa
i'm so proud of you
i know it's been a tough year for
everyone in more ways than one
but you have accomplished so many
milestones you've completed
goals that were hours so you rock
keep kicking ass can't wait to see those
capsules of yours
yeah man love you rosa